la conferencia internacional sobre libia
que se realizó en berlín por invitación
del gobierno alemán y del secretario
general de naciones unidas tuvo como
objetivo acordar los siguientes pasos
hacia la estabilización de ese país que
ha vivido una década de caos y de
violencia esos pasos incluyen un mayor
apoyo de la comunidad internacional así
como también un fortalecimiento del cese
el fuego si bien expertos aquí en verín
han cuestionado sus esfuerzos
internacionales asegurando que no han
hecho suficiente para frenar la
violencia en libia al gobierno alemán sí
reconoció los avances que ha habido en
ese país en los últimos meses en
particular con el gobierno de unidad de
transición siguiente el gobierno alemán
y en particular el ministro exterior es
algo más también reconocieron que en
libia enfrenta desafíos muy grandes
citando en particular la necesidad de
que se ponga fin a lo que es yo como la
interferencia militar extranjera
asegurando que debe respetarse el
embargo armamentístico y apoyar también
el proceso político que debería llevar a
la realización de elecciones previstas
para finales de este año